all right let's get to audience
questions for the week first one hey
David is a right to privacy still a
realistic expectation in 2019 given the
technology that is now ubiquitous so
sometimes with these it's easier to
start with the simplest form of the
answer like the most basic logistical
answer and then talk about the
implications so in a literal sense in
public there's no realistic expectation
of privacy there are cameras everywhere
there are all sorts of different
surveillance methods that are going on
via satellite if a government really
wants to follow you around they can do
it when you're out in public so in
public there is not in a practical sense
an expectation of privacy but that
definition of privacy has changed over
time and I'll get to that in private
people can decide whether to record and
there are laws that govern this if
businesses want to have surveillance
cameras inside their business most of
the time it's legal in bathrooms and
locker rooms it's not and it should
continue to be illegal I believe that it
should be disclosed if there is
surveillance I'm trying to think in
Vegas casinos where there are cameras
everywhere I don't know that I see signs
that say that you are under surveillance
at all times other than in the bathroom
and presumably it presumably in your
hotel room I think that that should be
there it may not even really be the law
but it is that business is right to do
it and then it's up to you to decide
whether you want to be a patron of a
business that is a recording video
surveilling etc the problem really goes
back to what do we mean by privacy when
we talk about data collection is that a
violation of privacy that was not in
considered by older definitions of what
it means to have a right to privacy
because what you have to understand is
that a hundred years ago we could say if
you're in public you don't have a right
to privacy and in 2019 we say if you're
in public you don't have a right to
privacy but what that meant a hundred
years ago is very different from what it
means today today you have the ability
to track someone almost 24/7 between
their
using the GPS on their phone and all
sorts of public and private cameras that
exist
out on the streets of our cities in
businesses etc a hundred years ago even
though the presumption of the right to
privacy might have been no different
than it is today from a legal
perspective in order to track someone in
the way that you can track them now
merely technologically you needed a team
to actually track that person 24/7 and
so even if the law has not changed and
even if we can say even though by the
way the Patriot Act and other types of
surveillance have modified the law
around other types of surveillance
including phone records and and others
but that's a little bit different than
what we're talking about here the
ability the practical ability to do this
type of surveillance has changed
drastically never having a right to
privacy in public ignores that today it
means something very very different to
be walking around in public than it did
a hundred years ago so should our
definition of privacy evolve even with
the same data often there's a question
of who gets to see it right I mean in
principle think about something like
medical records and the privacy that is
presumed to go along with those I might
be okay with those records being used in
some sort of aggregate anonymous way to
research illness but that doesn't
necessarily mean that I want my insurer
to have access to those records or that
I want those to have my name attached to
them in a way that is not private so
clearly in public there is no right to
privacy in the sense that many of us
imagine but I still believe that we
should have a reasonable right to
anonymity if we want it and that's where
the technological surveillance starts to
become a question mark realistically the
other thing we have to consider about
this is that as these new technologies
have been developed public opinion has
also shifted and will likely continue to
shift if you ask a 20 year old today and
a 40 year old and a 60 year old and an
80 year old when it comes to something
as
seemingly straightforward as right to
privacy in public when you're just out
in public you will have drastically
different answers from what is
reasonable from each of those groups and
I can't imagine that that's going to
stay the same over time as these new
technological means become more of an
everyday part of our lives when I write
an email when I think about it I tell
myself I have to be under the the sort
of operating under the the belief that
this is not necessarily private but I'm
not actually thinking of that every time
I write an email younger generations may
be actually thinking about it that way
or they may not because they don't care
and that is part of the shift in public
opinion around this that we've seen let
me know what you think when it comes to
a right to privacy what is reasonable to
expect and what is not